it must be great for the three of you to
have john back in the band
because john seems to be that catalyst
that that guy who makes you guys elevate
your game is that a fair assumption to
make because every time john's in the
band
the the band the band just seems
like it it goes to a certain level
john that's a good that that's a fair
assumption he is a
he's more than a catalyst he is a
catalyst
but he's our brother he's our family and
i think just being around him and seeing
how much he pours into what he does is
infectious it's contagious
um it's inspiring literally inspiring
not just like oh wow i'm inspired but
he offers ingredients and love and hard
work and for sure it makes us want to do
better work harder what made you ready
to come back for this album it was a
certain amount of
soul searching that i'd done
it seemed like i changed and grown
enough as a person to where
it felt like it would be a beautiful
thing to have another chance to do it
right i felt that way when i rejoined
the first time uh on a personal level
and on a musical level i had some new
ideas about where i thought those
relationships could go and it was the
same thing this time i just
i i was seeing
anthony and flea and chad through a
different lens than i had seen them
through when i quit not that either time
that i quit that it was specifically
anything to do with personal but
you know
having a personal relationship in a band
is is a hard thing you've got to be in
sync with four people
working as hard as they work doing
you know
going where they go doing what they do
almost thinking what they think
it's an intense thing to do you know and
so i've found for myself that that that
i've needed a i've needed to clear my
head of it and
try to figure out who i am as a person
and i really wanted to have that have
that closeness and that kind of
vulnerable interaction with them again
it must have been really kind of a
no-brainer right or or did you guys have
some discussion and say gee could do
could we go back to start working again
together
i mean there was definitely something in
the air because without knowing
that
john wanted to come back and without
knowing that flea had
been having interactions with john
musically
suddenly i felt very overwhelmed with
the feeling of
how do we get john back
and i and flea and i had a very classic
moment where we went to each other
to say something important and he's like
i got to go and i was like no i got to
tell you something i got to and it was
just in the air it was time for john to
come back and i was shocked when flee
told me that that john was
interested and that he had been playing
with john and
you know there was there were no hard
feelings there were no resentments there
were no regrets the fact that we were
able to kind of keep things going while
john was away was sort of perfect in the
end because we were available when when
he showed up and
it was time for change